[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday the 5th
of October
2023 my name is Freddy gray I'm the
deputy editor of The Spectator and I
will be your host today
we're going to be focusing quite heavily
on politics and I won't say I'm afraid
because it has been a big political week
uh the Tory Party Conference has just
happened uh the labor party conference
is coming up um I'll be joined first of
all by Katie balls um our politics
editor and the author Anthony Seldon to
discuss uh how the week went for Rashi
sunak and his administration uh there's
Katie's cover piece here which I will
hold up again uh no doubt
and uh after that we'll move on and talk
to Tim Stanley the telegraphs Tim
Stanley about the state of conservatism
and ask the important question what have
the conservatives actually been doing
for the last 13 years and then we'll be
moving a little bit from uh the
political towards the spiritual and be
talking about Anglican Bishops in the
House of Lords uh and their bias towards
the labor party I'll be joined by James
heel to discuss that
topic and lastly are you a workaholic
apparently almost everyone is these days
uh I'll be joined by The Spectators
Workaholics
workaholic uh Douglas Murray to talk
about why he is so
unlazy but before we get going I would
like to thank our sponsors our brilliant
sponsors uh canac cord genuity wealth
management uh for supporting our show
canac cord our experienced wealth
planners and invest inv M managers who
offer unwavering support in these
challenging times visit canw wealth.com
for more information about them well
let's talk about the big story of the
week first and that is uh the Tory Party
Conference uh our cover piece is
inevitably about it uh battle begins
Katie balls on the coming contest I'm
joined by Katie now our politics editor
who's written that piece and the author
Anthony Seldon who has written seven I
think it is Anthony seven Prime
ministerial biographies Katie first of
all congratulations on writing this
piece because I was there not as long as
you were uh at the conference and you
seem to be doing endless events uh and
mingling and I'm not sure when you
managed to do it but it's a very very
fine article uh that sums up the state
of British politics rather well um let's
talk first about the speech uh because
obviously that's the big set piece uh
and I think it's fair to say it wasn't
quite the disaster that a lot of people
thought it would be um but perhaps it
hasn't set the world on
fire yes I think that is fair in the
sense that you had lots of talk ahead of
the speech because what ultimately
happened was a few weeks ago um a
snapper a very keen Snapper caught a
glimpse or in a photo of a government
document um suggesting that hs2 was
being looked up by the government that
then led to multiple stories about where
the second leg of hs2 could be scrapped
and when I got to the conference every
interview including those of the Prime
Minister the chanc and the transport
secretary became well we're in
Manchester if you're scrapping the root
um Birmingham to Manchester why didn't
you just say and it meant that in the
days ahead of the speech it was a bit of
a groundhog day for the Conservative
Party Conference and when Rich s got up
to speak I think people thought all hell
could break loose Ry and the Tory party
um if he were to announce this and
people such as myself I think even said
on this you know uh who would be for all
of rich like wanting to talk about hard
truths would he really scrap something
for Manchester in Manchester now it
turns out the answer was yes um as rishy
C tries to pitch himself as this change
candidate something kiss starma also
wants to do I think he almost is quite
happy to lean in to where he there are
some disagreements to where there is
some friction so there were three main
announcements he confirmed aing that
part of hs2 there's also a plan to
slowly phase out cigarette use uh
starting with 14year olds and then
finally there's a plan to scrap a levels
and bring in a new degree now I think
for Richie sunak to your point Fred he
thinks these are really big radical
policies and therefore are going to
capture their agenda and they I think
they are getting lots of people talking
is it enough to uh you know change
things and mean that the public see them
differently I think the jwelry is out on
that and also they are devices uh you
know within parts of the Tory party for
example that I think the cigarette ban
is probably the most internally Tory
divisive it probably plays better with
uh the general public and some labor
voters and Tory voters and nhs2 has seen
David Cameron come out and be wering uh
time after there but the view in number
10 is effectively uh we're going to say
at Leisa RI next stands for something
you might not like what he stands for
but he stands for something and they're
going to say kiss dama doesn't yes S I
wonder about that the the smoking ban uh
is referred to as a talking point and of
course hs2 was a very big talking point
um but there's a suspicion that rishy
sunak Administration are quite happy
with talking points like those um
because that means not talking about uh
very substantial problems with uh the
economy with the
NHS uh and with uh other aspects of
transport and and generally the sense
that British Society British Britain as
a country is not working very well do
you do you have that
sense so I think he is doing the only
thing that he can do which is to present
himself as the candidate of change let's
remember the context here is that no
party since the birth of modern British
democracy in 1832 with that Reform Act
uh has won five general elections in a
row and there's a reason for that that
uh there are common factors
uh that come to bear and uh make it very
difficult for that party and and so I
think he's done well I mean I'm talking
here as a head teacher in part from the
heads study at Epsom College where I am
at the head uh and I think the a level
is absolutely right and long overdue 70
years um it is a good Fair run for aals
Britain was a totally different place uh
when 70 years ago was devised uh we need
to move towards a broader more modern uh
examination system call it British Balor
what you will and I think he's right
about education and I think he's right
to give urgency in education which the
Tes did very well at the beginning of
the um 13 14 years under Michael Gove uh
under David Cameron AS prime minister
gave it huge um uh urgency and I think
he's right uh to return to it because
there's been there have been 10
education secretaries uh in the last 10
years which is of course absurd and I I
think you I like what he's saying about
smoking um and I the hs2 decision and um
pushing back on uh the rate of uh
greenfics uh politics uh even if they're
not always sensible policy I get all
that but you know it's not going to be
down to what he does or doesn't do and
it hasn't been so in the past let's just
if I got time just to mention three very
quick factors and then you can come back
and ask about them if you want to I mean
the first is that drags down long
serving governments of left Dan right uh
is the feeling is all beginning to
unpick and unad from the inside that
casy talks about in her uh really
excellent article uh and she mentions
Liz Trust stressing around at the body
conference you mentioned David Cameron's
speech is it just the beginning of what
happens uh as the party becomes much uh
less interested in the uh losing uh
prime minister than who might take over
uh that's the first thing that unravel
um long serving government second is
obviously the state of the economy over
which uh the Prime Minister number 10
and the treasury have um surprising
little control I mean I say surprising
it shouldn't be a surprise uh because so
much of the state of the economy is
decreed um in uh by forces outside their
control and the third is the Ze guys
just the sense that yeah it's time for a
change and we don't really know who this
other person is or party or what they
might do as long as they're not too
scary we just need to have anybody and
there's a sense of staleness and
Corruption uh boredom um so I think
those The Big Three uh um dis tantamount
disloyalty uh the economy and time for
change that will matter far more uh than
his I think you know Brave and correct
uh politics which is to try and be the
change candidate and to put the and to
create difficulty for labor next week uh
by you know really um uh bowling curve
balls at the starma team uh you you say
the a level reform is long overdue um
and you as Conference of head teachers
this week I wonder did most head
teachers share your view I I know
there's some concern uh in conservative
circles that uh there's too been too
much tinkering with qualifications with
exam systems and it's never really
turned out very
well I think if you get um 300
Independent School heads together in a
conference room you'll come up with 31
different opinions and that's um
precisely why they've become heads
because they do have opinions
uh but there's a general sense that it
is anomalous for Britain to have such a
narrow curriculum at uh the 16 to 18 age
that most other countries have a broader
uh Balor type of system uh and that
having um English and math all the way
through to the end of school is
important for whatever careers and
having a greater sense of a focus on
entrepreneurship uh and creativity more
practical education ation and bringing
together practical and academic
education so I think I think the Prime
Minister and his team have done well in
all of that um and inevitably it's going
to divide the education Community
because it always does uh but you know
70 years for any exam system I mean
that's a Hecker an Innings right ktie uh
the battle lines are drawn uh as you say
uh but mainly on the Tory side now
because of course got labor Party
Conference next um what are you hearing
about how labor might respond uh I mean
there's some talk today that uh with HS
to Rishi sunak has actually given them a
problem uh because are they going to
oppose it when it they're actually
pockets of support in quite strong labor
areas for uh Scrappy hs2 if it means
more investment in transport so has he
stolen a bit of their
Thunder I think he's definitely left
them some questions to answer um and
well you know you're stealing the
Thunder uh depends how they do so of
course this is the first time in a very
long time that labor conference has
taken past Taken part after Tory
conference and while I think most people
aren't sitting at home watching the
conferences minute by minute it does
have some impact at least on I think how
the political landscape looks because
right now it means we you know one of
the first times uh labor are going to
have to respond to the Tories um but
label will get the last word so imagine
in a week's time saying oh well you know
she soona who even remembers that
conference if it goes well for labor
that's what they want to do but there
are questions as you say on hs2 um
Rachel re wants to you know be very
careful with the finances and keeps
saying no to all these spending requests
from her Shadow cabinet so we're labored
to come out and say we will press ahead
with part two of hs2 that's 36 billion
that cannot be spent in other areas and
such as some of these new projects Ric
has announced lots of projects I think
some seem more sturdy than others after
24 hours you know since since he's um
talked about them but the point is uh
you could have you know local counselors
saying well uh the Tories are currently
committing to this project in my area
and if you stick with hs2 are you going
to do that so I think there's some
things there I think the cigarette one
in a way isn't too political um the only
thing is perhaps labor would have
announced it so has Ry sud beaten them
to it and West streeting the shadow
Health secretary has already be spoken
quite supportively of it so and it's a
free vote uh because it's a conscience
matter so I'd be surprised if that was
something where they they make too much
hay with it and then on education I
think the label will have their own
their own policies but I think when it
comes to Labor's battle lines um
speaking to figures ahead of this
conference so for example Rachel Reeves
and Her speech is going to try and Pitch
it as an economic choice to um Anthony's
point by saying that you know the choice
is stability including the economy this
is the you know the shadow Chancellor
speaking um with labor all risking
another four or five years of chaos with
the Tories and I think um you'll hear
lots of talk of oh who got a bigger
Queue at Tory conference Liz trust or
Jeremy Hunt and therefore I think where
labor is more comfortable at least for
now is actually making their dividing
lines on uh personality and party role
and policy they do have some policies
that are different to the Tories um you
think about green energy you think about
workers rights but I think work is St
Rich feel the most confident is trying
to just drag Rich down as being part of
a Tory party that is just filled with
infighting and I think that's going to
be a big theme and Anthony touched on a
very important word in politics which is
boredom uh and if you look at these
battle lines that are being drawn out uh
and we've discussed this before on on
spectator TV I think uh that it's
looking like the next election is going
to be something of a bore off uh with
both leaders trying to present
themselves as stable pragmatic uh and
and won't do anything to really sort of
uh disturb anything when at the same
time the public are crying out out for
change uh and for a different kind of
politics um who do you see winning a
bore off at the
moment yeah I think what's really
interesting about that is as you say
Freddy both parties have clocked onto
the fact that the public really want
change but yet they really want to do it
on their terms so rishy sunuk is doing
it in quite a
technocratic um rishy sunak way of
taking risk and they are bold on on
their own terms um but it is a far cry I
think from Boris Johnson proroguing
Parliament and so forth and kid St wants
to be changed but don't not too not too
much like change so as to scare any
voters so they keep talking about it but
it isn't anything too drastic I think
from V's perspectives when we're looking
at the different cartoons ideas to go on
the cover this week there was you know
two kind of almost wind up doll versions
of um Rishi S and K dama which I think
did did allude to the fact this could be
a a less exciting election and I think
the Jeremy Corbin versus Boris Johnson
2019 election it's going to feel so
different to this um I think it's
probably the first election where even
if the Tes try and weaponize brexit a
bit because of K Stam has passed it is
not going to be a brexit election first
and foremost um and therefore perhaps be
for a bit more like 2015 um and but when
you come down I suppose to which party
has the easiest job saying they are
change it is going to be kiss dama even
if is going to be a very flat election
um just in the sense that 13 years is
hard to R aide
so uh change not chaos is what both
people are trying to present anti I
wonder if we could talk about the media
culture uh and politics uh because you
have uh people like gar and andak trying
to talk about sort of stable stability
in politics and serious issues trying to
be serious grown-ups and so on uh but
you also have the BBC um obsessing over
Liz truss's event which you know was was
an interesting wrinkle was an
interesting story um and talking a lot
of the BBC and a lot of other media
talking about the far right uh takeover
of of the conservative party um I don't
think I'm biased in saying I don't think
that's a fair reflection of what was
going on at conference is the problem
slightly that whatever the Tories say uh
the the media culture is going to focus
on things that are unhelpful to
them so uh the uh media Freddy uh very
very broadly uh the papers are going to
look at the headlines uh today Thursday
I'm sure all the way into the weekend
will be broadly supportive of the
conservatives um and uh the broadcasters
uh will be broadly uh supportive of uh
starm obviously with the fracturing away
from the grip of the BBC um with all
kinds of New Media outlets and social
media I mean every general election uh
it becomes more and more difficult uh to
predict to control the media which is
precisely why the two operative figures
in this election will be Isaac lovo
managing the campaign for the
conservatives and Deborah Madson and all
the colors around starma because
everything that they breathe and up as
we know is designed by focus groups
because this is such a vital general
election for both of them which isn't um
I think I agree totally with Casey that
coming second is much better um that the
chores I'm sure HED to do what uh uh
happened with inheritance tax that so
mocked up Gordon Brown uh and his hoped
for an early general election when he
took over in 200 uh7 uh for those who
can remember uh back that far and I
agree with casy that it hasn't quite
gone uh that far there's nothing like uh
that spoiler in the spoilers that have
come out or uh to by the conference this
week
um and um I it is going to be uh a sense
of safety first as the 1929 general
election uh was uh and uh I agree also
that that interestingly brexit We're Not
Gonna thank goodness uh hear a lot about
brexit I don't think in this general
election it is going to be um uh it's
going to be exactly as I said at the
beginning uh it's pretty largely out of
richy suak and team Sak's hands it will
be the three factors that I mentioned at
the beginning uh the economy um and the
divisions within the Tory party KY badok
this uh trust uh others who feel that uh
uh sunak got the um Premiership U by the
back door and unfairly and that sense
that it really is time for a change and
all the uh the mudle and the relatively
low achievement of the Tores and that of
course is not totally their fault
because there was Global financial
crisis there was the brexit uh there was
coid and and the Ukraine war and and and
the inflation impact of of that I mean
it's unusual for a period of 13 years 14
years any government of one party to
have so many external factors knocking
the achievement off course but the
result is it has been a pretty low
achieving 13 14 years for anyone party
much lower than the touris between 1951
and 64 with 4 PMS or or labor
between 1997 and 2010 with just the 2
PMS they've had 5 PMs and I've lost I
can't count how many different sects of
State my numbers my math isn't that good
I should be better as ahead I
know you need you'd need a an advanced a
level uh in mathematics to figure out
all the I should have I would have been
a beneficiary of of of the British back
and being made to do mass and then I
could have counted that high uh Anthony
and Katie we will end it there but thank
you both very much for coming on to
spectator TV and Casey you should get
some
rest now as we've just alluded to uh one
of the tor's great problems is that if
not their greatest problem is that
they've been in power for 13 years and
quite a lot of the country doesn't
really think they've done much good um
Tim Stanley uh the telegraph Tim Stanley
who joins me now wrote a typically uh
brilliant piece for the spectator just
before conference about this uh it was
entitled what of the conservatives ever
done for us and Tim I'm going to uh do
that annoying thing reading out your
last line U I do recommend everyone
reads it but it's worth worth starting
with your last line because uh I think
it sums up the piece rather well uh this
government has pulled off the impressive
feat of turning millions of Voters off
conservatism uh explain what you meant a
bit there
please well I I the full quote is that
uh despite not having governed as
conservatives they've still managed to
turn people off conservatism which is is
quite an achievement and what I mean by
that is that if you look at the polling
uh most people now want well most
people's emphasis is upon tax and spend
in order to deliver good Services I
think the problem with this conference
and it's interesting to read my piece
and then view the conference and see
some confirmation of what I argued
problem with this conference is is not
focused on the basics of everyday life
it's not really talked about the NHS
it's got nothing to say about tax
because they're not touching that uh it
hasn't really made clear philosophical
conservative Arguments for typical
conservative policies because they're
not really implementing any in fact
Richi sinak speech was quite
schizophrenic uh this is a conference
which is very proud of having introduced
same-sex marriage but now apparently it
hates transsexuals uh this is a this is
a party which play in 2010 that it was
going to extend hs2 from London Houston
to Manchester but it had the bareface
cheek to announce from Manchester that
it wouldn't be doing the Manchester link
of the line anymore uh this is the
conference which is uh the party of
Liberty and the individual but it'll be
banning smoking uh for young people
there are all these many contradictions
and at the back of the the mind of the
voter is the greatest contradiction of
all which is being a party of change in
government so Rishi sunak saying not
just the last years have been one of
dead deadening consensus for the last 30
years he's going to overturn 30 years of
government and of consensus a friend
messaged me to say imagine if you were
married to the conservative party You'
be demanding a divorce because you've
had 13 years of abuse and neglect during
which they gaslit you and told you that
most of the things you thought were
happening were not happening and then
after admitting that those things were
happening they say to you but stay stay
with me darling because I believe I can
change all your friends would be saying
leave
him I'm afraid that I think most Motors
right now whatever sunx is however good
his intention and there are individual
ministers who I think genuinely do want
to change things like sella Braverman
most voters are going to say I would
feel like an idiot to vote for the party
which for the last 13 years has done
this how can you possibly justify that
to yourself well it's interesting is it
not that there's almost now a
Nostalgia for the Cameron coalition
government because it it's felt widely
now that when the conservatives working
with the libdems they had more of a
drive they had more of a sense of of
purpose of mission uh than they do now
yeah I I I think that's for two reasons
one is because they of course uh were
entering government and you're better at
government when you come out of
opposition which is sort of paradoxical
because you have less experience of
being in government but what you have
done is you've gone away and thought
about what you want to do and you come
up with a plan plan for how to do it
Boris J Johnson Dominick Cummings proved
you can't do that running you can't just
run straight into office without having
properly first figured out how to do
stuff whereas Cameron and Osborne came
in with a set of things they wanted to
do and they got those bits done and then
because they were handcuffed with the
lib Dems that actually played to Cameron
Osborne's philosophical leaning they
were liberal Tories and so it meant that
some of the harsher stuff around
austerity was then softened by lib Demi
type stuff which they probably would
have done anyway like lifting low paid
workers out of tax but looking back over
the the overarching 13 years there's no
getting away from it that the Tories
have never governed as efficiently or
radically as when they were in Coalition
with the lib Dems and probably their two
biggest achievements in domestic policy
in these 13 years have been education
and Universal Credit and they both began
under the lib demems I'm not saying that
we lived in policies far from it one was
Michael goes was very controversial at
the time education academization Etc
same goes with Ian Duncan Smith the
Tories were accused of uh leading to the
deaths of disabled people Etc both were
very controversial very typically
traditionally conservative policies but
they got them through they got them done
and we have seen results and they
happened under the Cameron years whereas
the the supposedly most radically
conservative most right-wing period the
post brexit period it's very difficult
to say domestically what emerges from
that as a legacy well there are two very
big excuses uh in these 13 years and you
touched on this in your piece one is
brexit of course and and of course the
conservatives are the party of brexit
but it there's no denying that the
several years spent um rowing over
brexit trying to get brexit done uh has
obscured a lot obscured a lot of
everything else got in the way of a lot
of other governing um and then of course
the bigger one in many ways is the
pandemic because that came just at a
moment where you had a brexit government
uh with a significant majority and even
if as you say they were sort of uh car
crashing an agenda in uh they had an
agenda but the pandemic really did
Scupper it I think that's fair to say
absolutely and they were winning
elections they won a historic majority
in the midst of the chaos of brexit and
it's most chaotic during a
constitutional crisis and they were
winning by elections they were doing
well in local elections so plainly
brexit uh did cause political problems
it also led to the a number of quite
talented Pol politicians leaving the
party uh as a result so they lost just
some of their talent they lost Cameron
over it they lost Osborne over it so uh
because they they stepped down and said
we don't want to stay in charge for for
when it's being implemented so it caused
a problem but it wasn't an electoral
liability on the contrary it gave the
Tores an in to the red wall the bigger
economic social and political crisis was
lockdown and I and and when I write
negatively of the Tories as I said I
think they may failed to make a case for
conservatism I think they've been very
uh schizophrenic in their policymaking
but in their defense almost every person
who was in charge during the lockdown
initially got some public support
because people rallied around the
government of the day and the actions
they took but almost all those
governments have been subsequently
kicked out I really think of Trudeau
still Clinging On by his fingertips so I
it was very difficult to put your
country through lockdown and not pay an
electoral price for it and for the T is
it's is just being deferred because of
the nature of the British electoral
system and another thing you point out
in your piece is the growth of British
self-hatred which is it's quite a strong
tradition in Britain um to hate
ourselves but uh you point out that I
think in 2013 uh 54% of Brits said uh
that Britain was better than most other
countries that's now dropped to
34% uh and nobody can uh ignore the
sense of Gloom that pervades not just
over the Tory party but over the country
generally there's a sense and a lot of
it is to do with brexit I think there's
a sense that this country has lost
something yeah uh it's to do with the
politics of brexit it's to do with the
economic and social decline that we've
experienced because of the pandemic it
leaves the toour in a difficult position
which is that in 2013 a populist
right-wing strategy might have been a
54% strategy uh but now it's a strategy
that only commands the support of about
a third of the country because a lot of
people have lost confidence in their
country and not not quite so sure about
what it stands for anymore or how to
articulate those barriers or how to feel
good about it we've seen in the last few
weeks a complete synthesis almost of GB
news and the Tory party the Tory party
has doubled down on populism at the same
time as the GB news has more sort of
faifi his relationship with the
conservative party the risk that both of
them take in this is that the authority
of populism rests on it being popular
what happens if the Tories lose the next
election where does that leave populists
because it will send the signal that
actually the claim that you are speaking
for the silent majority doesn't hold if
you're no longer a majority of the
public and it's actually possible that
populism has alienated some of that
majority and turned it into a minority
it's actually turned some people of the
British project same as a problem in
America where Trump IES constantly claim
that they speak for the real America
well it it looks from polling like 65
like 55% at least of the country is no
longer real American by that metric so I
I think this is going to be a difficult
thing brexit has pushed the Tories in a
particular direction at the same time as
that direction has begun to lose some of
its grip over the public because of the
chaos uh and the the political
controversy associated with it and a
figure uh who proved to be popular uh at
conference this year was Liz truss of
course uh and what you're talking about
there in terms of the the conservative
party being the party of the working
class in in many ways uh in the future
right-wing parties being the party of
the working class Liz trust's agenda is
not something that appeals to the
working class but it is extremely
popular uh with um if you like the
ascendant right uh in bristan okay I
okay first of all I had when she was in
power I wrote sympathetically about her
agenda so this I'm not saying this as a
critical commentator but I think the
idea that the Tory Party Conference was
in some way bowled over by Liz truss is
not accurate I attended that meeting
that she spoke at and I would say that a
significant number of members had gone
along for the same reason that
journalists went along to find out what
she had to say and if she would get
through it without doing a lizm uh there
was a slightly theatrical quality to it
uh there was a much I think there was a
more enthusiastic attendance for the new
conservatives meeting which is the sort
of Boris johnsonian populist
conservative meeting run by Danny
Krueger upstairs a little bit later so
I'm I'm not convinced the party sold on
her I I I was I found it curious that
Nigel farage turn show chose to show up
to her meeting and Associate himself
with her because there's an aspect of of
Nigel which really connects with the
public which is the anti-immigration
culturally conservative aspect but on
economics I don't think Britain is a
neoliberal economic country it you just
look at the polling it's not not only
people not agree with neoliberal
economic Solutions they're not their
priorities their priorities are services
like health healthare and education not
tax growth business Tech and all this
sort of stuff so it's a real problem for
populism uh if it's going to I if it's
going to embrace the neoliberalism of
Liz truss I think it's actually going to
find itself losing support and those
people are more likely to gravitate
towards labor which has worked out that
if if it can combine a moderately Social
Democratic economic agenda with just
staying quiet about culture there's a
lot of votes to beat hubber up and you
wrote a very funny sketch about soel
bradman's speech in the telegraph but
soel Bradman uh seems to be possibly
emerging as the leading figure of this
new conservative movement you're talking
about Danny Krueger and so on am I right
in saying that yeah no I think you're
right it feels as though the next
leadership contest is going to be among
women uh and the most obvious contenders
are sella bravman KY Bok I don't know
about Liz truss maybe not Liz truss
maybe PR pretty Patel on behalf of Liz
truss and then Penny Morton so it's it's
all about the women at the moment which
is is a fascinating Dynamic uh but I
think s bravman is is establishing
herself as the natural leader of the
populace and of course commentators
always say she's doing dog wristle or
she's saying this to get votes or that
was a leadership election speech yeah it
was but she also believes in it and I
think of all the people who I um who
I've spoken to in the course of this
week I think the person who is most uh
philosophically coherent and consistent
is probably sella Braverman and is
probably the one who uh touches a cord
best with the public uh I still think
she has some space to grow as a
political figure and as a a political
actor but nonetheless I think the new
conservative whatever they call
themselves movement I think that's
probably uh more likely to win votes in
the future than populist
neoliberalism there's been a lot of talk
lastly to about uh the Tory party
differentiating finally differentiating
itself from labor under sunak and and
creating clear blue water whatever the
phrase is uh do you think there's any
truth to that any validity in it do you
read anything in into a possible
tightening into the polls or do you
think the conservatives need to have a
period out of power in order to to
regroup and ReDiscover what they're what
they're what they're all about RI sunak
gave his net zero speech and there was
then one poll which showed that the
labor lead had had slipped to 10 points
which is still very high uh and so for a
little moment some Tories were were
excited about that and then another poll
came out that showed the leader
something like 22 points or to something
impossible to overcome uh the reality is
they're up against their record they're
up against the consequences of lockdown
they're up against the economic
conditions I think it's very difficult
for them to overcome that what they're
trying to do under sunak is establish
themselves as the consumer party and
interesting to watch sunak begin to
articulate that to say that politics
doesn't work the uh public services are
not good uh the Tory party is going to
be as s braveman said your Trade union
that might work it would work best in
opposition it's just a difficult
argument to make when you're the ones in
charge it's that age old Tory problem of
trying to run against the government
when you're in government and I just
think the voters are again I think
everything is going to boil down to I
can't get to see a GP for a month and
then it's only a phone call and I think
all the talk about uh men are men women
are women uh control the borders even if
you agree with all that stuff it just it
just feels crashingly irrelevant uh to
the very basic everyday problems with
government in this country and this
sense that it's not working well and the
the only thing that people think might
stop a labor government is uh the
shortcomings of K starm and I suppose
we're going to see that um at the labor
Party Conference next uh do you
anticipate uh a sort of bold labor party
presenting its Vision to Britain
successfully I I think the Tores have
said very little in the last few days
where they have spoken it's been on
really small stuff like we won't force
you to have seven bins and we'll try and
push back on 20 miles per hour it's it's
notable how small the Tory stall has
been I think the labor stall will be
even smaller as I keep joking we only
find out what a labor party policy is
when they announce that they're no
longer going to do it uh and and I think
they'll roll back even on private
schools and things like that leading
with nothing uh sunak has tried to
introduce the question of trust and so
his definition of trust is me promising
as little as possible but convincing you
that I can at least deliver that
starmer's version of trust is I won't
promise anything so you can't be
disappointed because I haven't actually
said I anything H and I I just don't
think that's very exciting but I still
suspect that he can Coast into number 10
purely on frustration and anger with the
Tory record Tim we'll leave it there but
thank you very much it's always a
pleasure of talking to
you now the Church of England always
used to be known as the party at prayer
but no sane person thinks that's true
today we have an article by Andrew
Roberts in the magazine this week I'll
hold it up because I like doing that uh
and it's called medson priests the
left-wing bias of the House of Lords
Bishops um James heel joins us now not
Andrew Roberts but uh a more than
adequate replacement for Andrew Roberts
uh James how bad is this bias uh to what
EXT ENT is it tor is moaning about the
bias and to what extent is this bias
very real so Andrew Roberts in this
piece um analyzes voting records in the
House of Lords and he's come up with the
Staggering statistic that since 2021 the
current session of this Parliament uh
more labor votes have been cast with the
government in the House of Lords than
the Bishops which basically means that
you know the Bishops really have become
in some ways The Unofficial opposition
to the government in the upper house now
there's two ways to look at this I think
Robert's case and the way he makes this
argument is that effectively the
leadership of the Church of England has
moved to the left since the 1960s less
people going to the church but
conversely um the liberal Roots um
enacted upon by the leadership of the
Church of England has only gone one way
and that's continuing in that direction
the other way to look at it of course is
that increasingly uh the conservative
party and the government have little
truck with the uh Church F leadership
there was a story I'm loathed to plug
other Publications but RX in turn tally
Fraser wrote a very good piece for
politics home which made the Sunday the
Saturday Telegraph Splash last week
talking about so bravman the Home
Secretary had repeatedly refused to to
meet Justin welp to discuss the small
boats crisis so I think really it shows
the two institutions of the state um
coming apart the Tory party is less
interested in what the church is saying
the Church of England is increasingly
very vocal about attacking the
government and as D Roberts makes in
this piece points out in this piece it's
a whole range of issues so the bishop of
leads for instance has spoken on
everything from Boris Johnson's meeting
with Alexander leev to the sugra report
to voter ID so it's a whole range of
things not really considered the moral
conscience issues the church
traditionally would focus on it's
interesting with Justin wiby isn't it
because I remember when he arrived uh
everyone thought because there was a lot
of moaning about ran Williams as
Archbishop of Canterbury that he was uh
sort of you know a progressive um and
and a lefty a bearded Lefty uh but uh
and it was sort of thought that Justin
wellby would be more pragmatic more of a
Evangelical conservative that hasn't
been the case at all it's been the
complete opposite and now ran Williams
seems like a uh very thoughtful and
reasonable spiritual person in
comparison I was CH to one Tor MP a few
weeks ago said that only an old atoni
former oil bun could embrace the green
left agenda like this you know um I
think yeah I think that really there's a
very sort of series of opinions which
are quite fashionable and certain
sections of you know considered opinion
and the church doesn't really seem to
challenge that I mean what was also so
striking is that you know it would be
very different if the whole church was
going in One Direction but as Robert
says in his piece um you know between 55
and 66% of Anglican worshippers
supported brexit whereas all 24 Bishops
and the two archbishops at the time
supported rain so are those views within
the church really being reflected at the
height of its leadership um to a large
extent this is the story of us living in
a in a post-christian society in many
ways um and you know Pope Francis the
Catholics are not immun Pope Francis
gave a a lecture on the environment I'm
not saying the environment is
necessarily a green issue but it
certainly he was sounding a lot more
like Greta thunberg than the previous
Pope Pope Benedict did when he talked
about the environment and I wonder to
what extent it is that uh the religion
of our time now it's not an original
point but it is progressivism is
identity politics in many ways and so
the Church of England inevitably uh
genuflect before that uh and follows
after the religion of our time I think
it's very much about the question of you
know the church having faith in what it
stands for and I think there was a third
of figure out the other day saying a
third of church bdon um priests actually
believe sorry VI don't believe actually
in the resurrection of Christ yeah um so
I think that it's real case of self
confidence lacking in the church I think
the leadership has been called into
question for 60 years or so I don't see
that that changing anytime soon the
interesting thing of course is that
given the change since the 1960s on the
you know theological Dimension here is
that going to be reflected in our
constitutional elements too the reason
why of course we've got this in a sort
of political discussion here is there
are 26 Bishops and archbishops in the
House of Lords that's part that's always
been the case we've always had an
established church I think some on the
right now questioning that should
continue to be the case as you say
Freddy given that this increasingly kind
of postchristian society soy um and also
you know in Robertson in the days in the
legislature um the Bishops when they
stand up all the other members of house
laws have to sit down because they
respect but his whole point is that that
kind of um you know revered position in
society in the House of Lords that's no
longer being reflected in the society
and I think although he stops short of
this in his piece increasingly there is
a sense of should those Bishops still be
allowed to be there in the House of
Lords well it's not a recent thing isn't
it that uh you know the the appeal of
anglicanism for a long time has been
that it's you know for Hardline
Catholics uh uh waffley you know it
doesn't force people to embrace the
difficult truths of uh of
Christianity and I mean but what it did
always stand for was uh tradition the
monarchy patriotism to a certain extent
um and that is something that has has
vanished from the church or is Vanishing
certainly and I think if you look at the
concern around the parishes the number
of churches that have been closed across
the country in recent years that's one
element of it also you look at the
church's um involvement in things which
are quite I think which are out of step
with what his own members believe on you
know to do with some of more thorny
issues around race and reparations Etc
there's been a bit of anger and
disappointment over that I suppose it's
about selective involvement when you
choose to intervene on certain political
issues you're suggesting there should be
given more weight and forbearance than
others um and I think that as you say
there's a say perhaps that the Church of
England hasn't really reflecting what
the Ley would like them to be arguing
about and talking about and it's
interesting is that it doesn't seem to
adapt because it is often more
conservative more Evangelical parishes
that are thriving uh whereas uh you know
as Andrew Roberts says the the uh
parishes which which Embrace kind of
very Progressive agenda tend to empty
out and eventually close uh why do you
think the Church of England and other
other religions can't really see that I
think it's really interesting and he
talks about how um other faiths as well
you if you making a case political
argument for be given representation you
look at those religions that are growing
in bris of course they probably might
not be uh card carrying labor types uh
if you he makes the point you know
Jonathan Zach of course was the chief
Rabbi for many years and he was seen as
having a real Affinity with Margaret
Thatcher and his speeches and
interventions always reflected that I'm
not too sure that's the reasons why
they're sort of failing but I think that
you know if you look at the kind of R PA
60 years there hasn't been any kind of
reversal of that Trend towards more
liberal alism um even that's despite the
way in which certain voices like John
sentu were very popular within the
public as a whole so um other question
is will the church being want to change
anytime soon I think judging from their
recent you know church house conference
is probably not probably not but perhaps
the House of Lords might yes uh and the
the key Point here is that uh people who
may have stood up formerly for that
conservative minded people who believe
that it should have an element of
stability and tradition within it um and
that the church freom can represent that
they might be up for
dissolving uh the role of the Bishops in
church or introducing different faiths
more now because uh certainly those
Bishops those uh spiritual Lords uh are
not um in favor of tradition in any way
yeah certainly sort of you know might
have sort of Catholic representation or
Pentecostal representation um to give
some examples of Borden out in the
Christian faith as you say I think the
key Point here is that you know the
concern around balance and if the
numbers in the House of Lords really
goes back I'd say you for many decades
but a lot of conservatives would place
the blame squarely on Tony Blair who
then introduced this idea of having uh
the idea that you should you should
mirror the representation of the House
of Commons in the House of Lords from
the late 1990s onward so he got rid of
the hereditary peers and thereafter he
wanted to have you know a certain number
of Labor peers reflecting the number in
the House of Commons trying and balance
that out of course that was really a
great pretext for creating huge dozens
and dozens of number of new labor peers
and so I think the whole question that
House of Lords is one something that's
really risen and Fallen throughout the
last 10 years or so of conservative
government but this is one particular
issue there's 26 Bishops or so if you're
really meant to be these kind of you
know great speakers of truths and
someone who can add sort of moral weight
in the house of laws but actually you're
just reflecting one party view there are
real problems with that and I think now
is I think among certain Tory peers and
I sure to say Lord Roberts is one of
these you know a Boris Johnson creation
a real tension there about what they
think the future of the upper house
should be and it shows to me how I think
often a long time the church the the
House of Lords was considered the much
more Gentile chamber increasingly I
think there's um much more partisan
notes being um being injected into the
Upper House James Hill thank you very
much
indeed finally let's talk about
workaholism uh a lot of people claim to
be Workaholics but are they really uh
Idris Elber the actor has claimed that
he is a workaholic and Douglas Murray
our columnist uh has picked up on this
point in his latest column Douglas first
of all let's let's start with the one
you would say you might qualify as a
workaholic it's possible uh but I think
that Mr Elber is uh in some kind of
error about one specific thing which is
he says that he's had to be in therapy
uh for the last year or so because of
his uh workaholic Tendencies he says
that one of the problems he's found is
that it's better he he he finds it
better to be say 10 days on a film set
than sitting on a sofa with his family
and he says there's an added uh Horror
in this
which is that the film
industry uh rewards him massively for
working like that and um I'm not sure
that there's a problem with the
incentive structure there um it if if
you're paid a lot of money to do
something you do well like Elber does um
then you should do it well and I think
that this among other things the
pathologization of everything the
medicalization ation of everything the
therapizing of everything if that's the
term um is is is not that helpful Elbert
is just a very good actor at the height
of his powers and uh people want to
reward him for working well now do some
people have a problem with work life
balance oh for sure um but I don't think
that's the same thing as um uh forms of
like drug problems or alcohol problems
or anything else I think it's just
another example of the pathologization
of what used to be pretty everyday
Behavior yes and possibly that we've
moved into a different phase uh of of
social life and of of human life that
we've become confession holics uh oh
yeah absolutely people are addicted to
publicly particularly with social media
now where everyone regards themselves as
their own kind of celebrity uh people
are addicted to talking about uh the
problems that they go through to make
themselves seem more interesting yes and
and um and and the best way as you say
is to sort of say look I've I've really
been storing this up for a long time but
there's something I've got to confess
and I I you know I I'm finding it really
hard but like help me with this guys and
uh I'm in therapy for working too much
and then everyone is meant to say
stunning and brave or something like
that and um yes I mean just sort of
gritting your teeth and getting on with
it doesn't quite pass Mustard anymore
everything's got to be a confession as
if you've got as a say as if as if
you've got problems when in fact the
only problem that Ela has is is great
success and uh as I mentioned in in the
column my view is that almost everybody
who is successful would count as in this
new pathologizing era as a workaholic I
know nobody who has uh you know made a
fortune on their own without inheriting
it who hasn't worked like anything
through most of their lives now their
children and grandchildren are quite
often good at putting their feet up and
reflecting on the nature of themselves
uh but it's it's not common that that
people who actually are self-made and
successful you know sort of have a lot
of me time the most obvious example I
give in the column is Elon Musk you know
people sort of think it's it's weird
that that that that that Elon Musk slept
on the floor of one of his Tesla
factories when he was trying to get the
the model through well that's an example
of somebody who would qualify as a
workaholic but he also produced the most
successful um non- diesel powered car
and is currently try working to get to
Mars and that's not somebody who really
needs to put their feet up a lot more or
have a lot more me time um that's
somebody who's doing stuff and that's
admirable I don't think it should be
sort of medicalized yes and to what
extent we in our one of our sections on
this show we were talking about uh
living in a post-christian society and
of course Max vber and the Protestant
work ethic probably one of the most
important books of the last 200 years in
some ways uh identified the importance
of prostatism and its work ethic in the
development of human civilization of
Western
Civilization uh do you think to with s
to not to get too serious about it but
do you think that that's what's going on
here is that we've actually lost the
sense that work is is an integral part
of what it is to be a human being what
it is to be
fulfilled well um first of all as I
mentioned in the piece uh most
Workaholics are Workaholics because they
are doing a task that they enjoy
and or are good at um you can be a
workaholic in an area of work that you
don't like and usually that's for
another reason which is you're providing
for loved ones and that that's a
particularly male characteristic and a
very Noble characteristic um but yes I
there's definitely the sense that uh um
a falling away of a certain form of as
you what you describe as a Protestant
work ethic a famous uh hymn uh which I'm
going to mangle misquote but uh the um
who sweeps a floor as for thy laws makes
that and the action fine a famous 19th
century hymn the idea being you know
whatever you do if you do it for the
right cause in that case for god um then
it doesn't matter whether you're
sweeping floors or doing anything else
uh I I think there's definitely a sort
of sense particular in in in the work
societies that we've created now that
unless you're totally happy with your
job you know you should sort of move on
and find something that suits you more
and that's partly because the the
largest significant change in work ethic
in the last 60 years has been the
movement from the person who does a job
however menial but provides for their
loved ones being a person of worth
becoming the person doing a menial job
is a like a
loser and and that obviously has changed
the whole uh Spectrum oh or is it that
we have become uh spoiled not just
financially as the world's become richer
but spoiled by Pleasure uh in the sense
that now when people have to do work
which often isn't pleasurable even if
you enjoy your work there are bound to
be parts of it that you don't enjoy but
anything that you don't enjoy is seem to
be uh triggering or damaging somehow uh
is is that a
problem uh well that that's definitely I
mean I mean all of the the the surveys
show uh Millennials who don't want to go
back to the office
uh for more than um like 30 minutes a
week and that's for the lunch hour uh
that that stuff is definitely you know a
problem and it's something that's
obviously been exacerbated by lockdowns
and events of recent years I mean I
mentioned that there's a famous
Iceberg of success that that some school
children have still shown that that that
everything everything below the surface
is all the work uh that that creates the
ability to see anything above the
surface and not get autobiographical by
mentioning the piece for the first seven
years or so of my own career I never
went on holiday uh I didn't once I
couldn't afford to and I couldn't I
couldn't pass up the opportunity of work
and a lot of people when they're
starting off have that experience you
don't dare say no to anything because
you fear that if you say no to anything
even for one week uh you might not get
asked again well I mean is that healthy
I think so actually when you're starting
off because when you're starting off in
any career you like better pedal like
hell and uh the idea that the world owes
you endless time to reflect or you know
relax is is just not true and apart from
anything else and I fear this is
particularly the case in British culture
at the moment apart from anything else
it suggests that there are sort of
several options in life one of which is
to sort of put your feet up and this
isn't theoretical by the way as we've
commented a lot in the magazine you know
one in five people who are of working
age and perfectly fit and able to work
in our major cities do not work and are
paid by the state not to work well you
know there's many many times the
population of Britain in China who are
willing to work many many times what the
hardest working people in our society
work in order to get the lifestyle that
we seem to think is our right and it
isn't so uh I wish there was a I wish
there was a little bit more work
alcoholism in in the UK uh we could do
with it and we could do with a bit of
shaming actually of the people who just
want to put their feet up sit around and
eat Doritos until the perfect job comes
around CU it's not going to yes although
you sounded quite tempting the Dorito is
tempting me slightly but but the the you
also touch on important you you are a
confession holic to a certain extent
because you're a columnist and you touch
on the fact that you've come to realize
that your irritability
is
monetizable can you
explain well I mean you know that better
than anyone Freddy having been on the
receiving end of my irritability many a
time no I um I do mention that I
mentioned in passing that of course
everything America is medicalized in
particular and that that of course now
now comes to the UK I mentioned that a
friend of mine from California recently
uh told me that he'd been given a a new
medication by his doctor uh uh that was
to treat his
uh slight
irritability and um uh he we talked
about it he said it somewhat helped him
in the workplace and he asked if I
wanted to try it and I I said it's a
hard no uh for two reasons the first is
there aren't enough pills uh to trunch
my intense irritability with almost
everything
um almost everything in the world um uh
and secondly that if I was to trunch
myself with anti- irritability uh
medicine um within about a fortnight I
think I'd be completely out of work uh
because I'd be uh writing at best
columns about the joys of spring uh the
fact that kittens are quite nice uh
puppies are charming and uh I think I'd
be writing without any insult to Country
Life I might manage about two columns a
year for Country Life about vs or
something you you do write about you do
write about
poetry irritability is not your only oh
yes I mean I'm I I write about a whole
range of things I don't just write about
the things that that that annoy and
aggravate me I also try to write about
things that I love but but it is quite a
good test for a writer to to um just
check your irritability at the
irritating things of the world and I I
would think that you know the first
thing you do when you get up in the
morning is just check that you're still
irritated by all of the human idiocy
which lays itself out before us every
day like a Great Buffet um and if if if
if it doesn't uh spark some kind of
response and then the chances are that
you've you've overindulged in something
else the night before yes well look in
the mirror and if you don't hate
yourself uh you should be worried yeah
that's I I don't have that one Freddy I
think that's one you have but I get okay
yeah that's a I don't look that much in
the mirror uh because of that uh Douglas
I would love to carry on talking about
this but I can't be bothered to carry on
this and I'm finding it quite irritating
it's quite getting irritating so we'll
wrap it up there but I've got work to do
I've got work to do gray unlike some of
you uh I'm going to go off and feed some
other
addiction that's it for this week uh I
hope that you have bothered to watch us
all the way through to the end of the
show I'm sure you have otherwise you
wouldn't be uh listening to me right now
um before we go before we wrap this up
uh I should thank
our sponsors canac cord genuity wealth
management um for sponsoring the week in
60 minutes canac cord will provide you
with the experience you need to help you
build your wealth with confidence visit
Cano wealth.com for more
[Music]
information